and finally
the fifth lesson she taught me
through words through her actions
is about love is to put love
out into the world
her husband
grandpa gregory
died when he was 58 in 1986
she loved him her whole life she loved
him
after he passed away and that love
while quiet in terms of her not
talking to me about it was always there
in the background was always in her eyes
the unshakeable love
so that's the love between her and her
husband my grandfather
there's something about loyalty
about deep unshakable human connection
in that
that stayed with me i seek that kind of
love with with friends
with really close friends i seek that
kind of love with the world around me
and i definitely seek that kind of love
with a life partner
with a person that i could uh how does
the saying goes uh
ride or die with i can bury the bodies
with them
you know it's kind of a bond that's
stronger than any
any other thing in this world a bond
that's stronger than any
fundamental force of physics she
uh i could see it in her and something
in that
stayed with me but bigger just love
love of life love of the ups and downs
of life
love and gratitude of everything around
me
she had that this glowing joy
that's not a simple joy but a deep joy
that acknowledges the
that life is suffering that life is hard
and that love is hard but to
appreciate it anyway the whole of it not
just the ops
the whole of it
she taught me to love people love
life love the world no matter what the
world does to you
and to love unconditionally simply
and to not be afraid to be cliche
to be simple
naive because that's what love is
it's quite simple
love is the answer as
some guy on some podcast once said
you